Kumail Nanjiani
and we are so excited to announce this
year's Oscar nominees so let's not keep
anyone else out there waiting
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Stanley has an almost sixty two-year-old
man having a Oscar nomination ladies and
gentlemen please welcome Academy
governors Rory Kennedy and Roger Waris
Williams hi I'm and it's so great to be
here I just thought I would start with a
little advice which is that if you go to
the Sundance Film Festival I highly
recommend that you watch films and don't
go skiing like I did anyway it's so
great to be here tonight to celebrate
these incredible films that these
filmmakers have brought to us both the
shorts and the features and it's just
such an honor to be amongst you and to
have this moment to really celebrate the
work that you've done over these last
couple of years many of you so thank you
and I will say out of about three and a
half hours ago the voting is done so no
matter what no matter what you say up
here or do up here it's not gonna affect
your vote so we really want you to go
all out tonight reveal your true selves
but no I um I do want to just take a
moment to to really acknowledge the the
sheer brilliance of of the films that
came out this year and as a governor of
the Academy I've been approached by so
many other members in the Academy and
other governors from different branches
saying how remarkable this group of
documentaries are and you know I think
it's really an outstanding group of
films this year in particular and has
really stood out so we're so proud of
you and I'm so proud to be associated as
a documentary filmmaker with you all and
and to be in this branch and be
connected to the work that you do so
thank you for your incredible efforts
and your talents and we're so happy to
be here tonight to be able to to
acknowledge that and and celebrate that
artistry and and the beauty that you
bring to these films and all the work
that it entails and bringing it to the
to the screen and these incredible
stories that you brought to our lives so
thank you all to the filmmakers and I
know the Academy itself is incredibly
supportive and and and proud of your
films as well and I've been as I said
told that over and over again by
different members but the Academy is
very supportive of documentaries in
general and so I want to thank them for
hosting this night for us and for
bringing these films to such a such a
wonderful audience but also to recognize
all the work they do over the course of
a year to celebrate documentaries this
year for example we the governor's
brought the idea of celebrating the
shortlisted documentaries and and with
the support of the Board of Governors we
brought those 15 films to theaters all
across the country
during that short period and we thank
you and we we worked with the filmmakers
here who are here tonight we also worked
with the exhibit exhibitors and the
distributors and it was a really
wonderful experience all around and I
think that it's a program that we're
gonna help to do again next year and I
think a number of the other branches in
seeing the success that happened with
the documentaries in the shortlist
you're gonna try to replicate it as well
as well so we're also showing some
leadership in this branch and appreciate
you guys spearheading that and leading
us on this incredible journey so and
thank you to the Academy for all that
support for this beautiful art form it
is now my great pleasure to turn it over
to to my friend and to my colleague and
amazing extraordinary documentary
filmmaker Roger Ross Williams Thank You
Rory you memorized your speech um so
yeah it's been an incredible year for a
documentary films and you know what's
amazing this year is that we have an
amazingly diverse group of nominees um
you know as um as one of the few black
governor's on the board of governors for
me diversity is essential really
important um you know I am I think that
the Academy
the documentary branch especially needs
to reflect the world we live in so I
just want to talk a little bit about
some of the work we've done over the
last few years we've made great strides
under the Academy's a 20 25 year
diversity initiative the documentary
branch has added over 80 new diverse
voices to our branch in those last few
years I think a couple years ago we had
only 7 Latino members in the whole
entire documentary branch
we added 11 more last year and we are
pushing hard to change that demographic
because that's a problem we in the
branch we have 48 percent of the
documented branch or female and but this
year I sort of challenged a branch to
reach gender parity 5050 the documentary
branch which is so progressive and and
one of the most diverse diverse branches
in the Academy should reflect the world
and we should have gender parity so I
challenge all that anyone in this room
is a member of the documentary branch to
nominate a woman because this year we
can get to 50/50 gender parity speaking
of change we sort of changed the way
we're gonna do this event tonight we are
actually instead of the panel I'm sure
all the filmmakers have done a lot of
panels recently and they're sick of
panels so we're not gonna do the Q&A
panel what we're gonna do is we are
gonna invite each filmmaking group up to
this podium they will say for five
minutes introduce their clip so they'll
say a story it's it can't be thank yous
though it it really needs to be a story
about your film or your process or you
know whatever you want to say but not
think not thanking everyone and I'm
gonna take a moment right now and thank
everyone who worked on all the films so
you know so all of the you know the
composers and the cinematographers and
the musicians and even the finance ears
everyone who worked on the film let's
just surround the bus to thank all of
them get it all out of the way
[Applause]
so um I'm going to introduce the short
subject documentaries tonight these
films have often played a vital role in
illuminating the difficult and
challenging subject matter this year's
nominees include a film that forces us
to confront racism in a very unique and
interesting way a film that challenges
us to think differently about the end of
life a film that puts a human face on
one of the most horrific humanitarian
crisis of our time a film that shines
the light on demagoguery that and that
seems as relevant today as it did 80
years ago and an inspiring film about a
group of young women fighting against a
deep stigma in their country documentary
shores which are close to my heart are
films that that are so powerful in a
short amount of time and can really
affect change and and really shine the
light on a circumstance in in our lives
so I would like now to invite to invite
and congratulate the documentary Short
subject filmmakers and you will each be
called to the stage one by one
congratulations to the nominees thank
you
please welcome the nominees for black
sheep ed perkins director and Jonathan
chin producer
well thank you it's a little
overwhelming and thank you very much for
having us thank you to the Academy is an
enormous privilege I know thank you I've
already broken the rules but it does
mean everything to be up here and
especially to be nominated alongside
films which I I think the world of their
their important films and and they're
beautifully made and and we both feel
very honored to be to be in the same
group in the same room as them it's
often said that documentary film is
having a bit of a sort of Renaissance
and it's a golden era and and it's an
amazing time to make these films it's
also really important time to make these
films and all the films in the room are
allowing us to view the world in a
really important and poignant way so
yeah we feel very privileged to be here
so our film is called black sheep it's
at about an extraordinary young man who
I'm very proud to say is here today his
name is Cornelius Walker and he's
allowed us into his world and told a
story which I think is very very
important I think as as documentary
filmmakers we're we're nothing without
brave young men and women of any age who
are willing to sit in front of our
cameras and bare their souls and I think
what Cornelius has done for us is is
astonishing I met him in a coffee shop
we've got mutual friends and with all
the sort of candor and charisma and
bravery that you see in the film he
started to tell me about this part of
his life and he blew me away and we
stayed in contact and we built a
relationship of trust and I eventually
asked him if you'd if he'd let me help
him bring his story to the world and
thankfully he said yes I'm totally
indebted to you Cornelius you're an
extraordinary young man and and we feel
very proud to have been a small pardon
and help him bring this story to the
screen just refused so we shot a master
interview over two days and then we took
a slightly unusual approach once we shot
the master interview and edited that we
decided that you know we could have done
visualizations through animation but
instead we decided to take a slightly
sort of hybrid approach we went back to
the actual town where these events
happen in Cornelius is life and all the
places that you see in the film are the
exact places where the events happened
20 years ago
we found young men and women who live in
that town and we persuaded them to help
us bring some of these difficult
memories in Cornelius's life to life in
front of him so everyone you see in the
film and non actors they're real people
who live there and and I think what
they've done in allowing us to tell this
important story is it's very important
and then yeah we we shot for a couple of
days and we we think it's a difficult
film it's a complicated film but we
think it's an important film and we hope
that it starts a conversation yeah I
mean as as people who know about short
films there's no business model for
short films you don't you don't get into
making a short film to make money or
anything like like that and this film we
hope has a life after this amazing honor
we plan to show it in schools
universities and hopefully it can
illuminate and express to other kids who
are going through issues of trying to
deal with their own identity issues and
hopefully this film can have a life
beyond this great honor so we're gonna
show a little clip now and hope that you
guys enjoy the clip thank you
I remember saying in a vaccine I'm
seeing the whole of Peckham just flashed
by rival arrives like you see the moss
the big back home library the church is
it was my London my multicultural London
to keep going I'll keep going on horses
and horses the cows will be going and
then um you know when you're driving and
you come the speed limits and the free
bars able to sleep wake up now see this
house
I want that describing this if I behave
yourself
the first week out there I stayed at my
house I didn't really go out they wanted
to do much and then one day my mom just
asked me to go to the shops for her
I remember walking out my house and
walking down this long path and all I
saw was white people like lychee just
different shades of white
so I go to the shop I want to enter the
shop everyone keeps looking at me like
staring at me and then cashier just gave
me this kind of like like why are you
it's like oh cool so next thing you know
I finish buying why needs to buy from
the shop and then I walk down the road
and all her hair is boy [ __ ] why no
look up I see a little boy : Anita and
then he looks at me just stares at me I
starts making monkey sounds
a basic got home I just I just kept it
to myself I could have tell my mom hey
the area muted to that kind of race is
is the way you can like return on the
house that he's just paid for and just
you know send us back and I don't go to
my dad telling him someone called me and
they go because he's gonna think I'm
weak and if I crying for my dad he's
gonna think I'm even weaker I got age I
was I was trying to look up to my dad I
was trying to be a man I was trying to
get my dad's love my dad's affection and
I just really wanted my dad to love me
if like he didn't love me he just had a
very hard way of showing it and at that
age I didn't want to show him any kind
of weakness remember when I was young
like whenever we you know , that angry
he were like you beat his chest as loud
as he possibly could and say I'm a lion
do you know what lioness he's a king of
the jungle it means you can't mess with
a lion and I just got Diane my sister if
he's a lion and I must be the son of a
line I can't show weakness so I just
went into my room I closed it though I
just mean as loud as I possibly could
but with nothing coming out my mouth
please welcome the nominees for endgame
Rob Epstein director producer and
Jeffrey Friedman director producer hi
Rob and I have been making documentaries
together for 30 years endgame is a
departure for us in a number of ways
first it's a most of our films have
dealt with historical subjects meaning
that we're telling stories about things
that have already happened and knowing
the stories we wanted to tell we've been
able to map out the structure of the
film before we began and this film is
almost entirely observational so we had
no idea how the stories would unfold as
we were shooting them in our previous
films we spent a long time researching
and doing pre interviews to to choose
the storytellers and the stories that we
wanted to tell and in this case we
didn't meet the storytellers or know
their stories until we walked into the
room and began filming them maybe the
the biggest difference is that in
earlier films who always worked with
professional crews it always made sense
to us to to work with experienced
craftspeople who who we knew would give
us beautiful pictures and sound and just
focus on directing in this case we were
the crew Rob and our co-producer Rebecca
Ferguson did most of the camerawork I
recorded much of the sound and because
of that we were we were able to be very
nimble in unpredictable situations we
were filming people as they approached
the end of life and we never knew when
somebody would take a turn for the worse
or the better but we were able to
respond to that and we were essentially
on call for 24 hours a day but just as
important or more important working as
such a small scale allowed us an
intimacy with the people we were filming
that I don't think we would have been
able to achieve otherwise one of one of
the hardest things about making this
film has been explaining to people what
it's about I have yet to come up with an
elevator pitch that doesn't evoke a look
of pain or even dread in the listener
which is maybe not the response you want
for an elevator pitch so in the making
of the film because it's such a heavy
subject we were always looking for a
moments of levity to ease the tension
and you'll be happy to hear that the
scenes were showing tonight contain
examples of some of that okay talk a
little bit about the scenes themselves
so we're showing three scenes in
sequence as they appear in film and the
first scene is with Mitra and bhaji
mitra was the main patient that we
follow and bhaji is her mother and at
this point in the filming filmmaking
process Mitra had been in and out of
consciousness but this particular night
she was in great form and we got to
experience her and all of her humanity
her humor her curiosity her love for her
family her love for life or just general
goodness all came shining through in
this one evening that we had with her so
that's that's the first scene the big
risk in a project like this is that you
know doing it by necessity it's so
intense and so intimate but the risk was
that it could also feel
exploitative and that's something that
we were certainly sensitive to all along
the way and usually is documentary
filmmakers we do everything we can to
get the subjects to not acknowledge the
camera to not acknowledge the the
filmmakers but in the second scene
you'll see we welcomed an opportunity
where that was really turned around and
we were acknowledged as as welcome
participants and we really were grateful
for that moment to let the audience have
that same experience that we had in the
moment and then the third scene is with
BJ Miller who's one of the two
palliative care physicians we follow in
the film this this scene was shot by
Rebecca my co cinematographer and our
co-producer who actually taught Geoffrey
and me how to use the gear so Thank You
Rebecca for teaching these two old dog
some new tricks and lastly I know we're
not supposed to do thanks but I would
feel remiss if I didn't thank our
documentary peers for getting us here
tonight we really appreciate the the
honor and the privilege to be among all
these nominees and we really really are
thankful for this recognition so thank
you very much
I'm glad that you ate more today that's
a good side you have look like you have
a little more color today this is my
major plan to be able to walk well
that's that's a good goal to keep in
your mind just being independent and
being your positive but I feel like I'm
against tomb walls thank you we'll have
them tonight for dessert yeah that's why
thank you okay I don't know if you want
to have a kid yeah you are thinking too
much
you and your wife it's one day today
your baby hundred-person is gonna be
bought is that what you did did you okay
Mitra I'm gonna go I have a wonderful
night with your sister husband it's
gonna be a great night tonight
[Music]
this is azita these are on the team of
my new friend
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nice shoes let's talk about that
shortness of breath but the bigger
reason to be here today is really to
continue to talk through this crazy
thing called death gave me an assignment
yeah you told me to make friends with
death yeah I have failed okay okay I
love to live yeah I am not accepting
this friends with death may be pretty
tough but maybe what a more meant would
have been have some sort of relationship
with with it not this subject it doesn't
need to be friendly at all just so that
it's less scarier than this unknown
thing in the closet that we never look
at never see never touch you know I
think the scary part is the unknown
mm-hmm and the lack of control oh yeah
is the unknown what its gonna feel like
to actually be dying or what its gonna
be like to be dead both because I don't
think that from where I said I'm not
sure that we can know what it like it
what it's like to be dead from here you
tell me if you feel otherwise but I so
so the given that that's not possible
next up would be okay if we can't change
that well maybe we can get used to it a
little bit so maybe in terms of being
dead part maybe that's our goal is so to
kind of get used to this idea of being
able to hold this idea of not knowing
holding the mystery yeah dad I think is
a better it's a more realistic goal than
solving that mystery yeah so maybe
trusting a little bit it could be
terrible but it could be wonderful this
part of my life is wonderful and who
would have thought I will tell you Tecla
from doing this work and being near
people who are at the very very end
everything I have ever seen would
suggest that wherever we're going
whatever abyss were meeting ain't so bad
really all I can say is from what I've
seen the people in the final moment
crossing over and from reports of people
who have kind of have gone and come back
and I don't know that that proves
anything but it's just maybe worth
noting that just empirically I don't
know that it's so bad reports seems
likely they're pretty been consistent in
are consistent and maybe it's enough at
least to warrant a little leap of faith
on your part please welcome the nominees
for life boat sky Fitzgerald director
producer Brynn Musa produc producer
[Applause]
Wow look at that had to do it okay um
several years ago I broke my hand in a
bicycle race and when I finally landed a
consultation with the orthopedic hand
surgeon I was fortunate enough to meet a
Syrian American surgeon who after he
looked at my hand a couple minutes said
yep
you need surgery and then struck up a
conversation with me about the Syrian
conflict and five minutes turned into 15
minutes and 15 minutes turned into
almost an hour and at the end of that
hour I handed in my card and asked him
if he would call me if he ever decided
to go to return to Syria that led to a
film called 50 feet from Syria and as we
finished filming that project I
suspected that the scale of the refugee
crisis catalyzed not only by the Syrian
conflict but by unrest throughout the
Middle East and northern Africa was
going to deeply influence the global
politics surrounding refugees and asylum
seekers and when the EU closed the
humanitarian corridor for asylum seekers
through Greece in 2016
nearly every NGO worker that we knew
told us that the EU authorities were not
prepared for what would happen next that
a central Mediterranean refugee route
leaving from the beaches of Libya in an
attempt for asylum seekers to gain UNHCR
vetting via the southern border of the
EU was going to result in a very high
mortality rate and when we began
researching this we discovered it was
already happening
we also soon learned that a small group
of private citizens had purchased an old
vessel a research vessel put together an
all-volunteer crew and set off to assist
the rafts of asylum seekers and I was
inspired and
Daanish and so like so often happens in
documentaries we talked our way to
access and eventually embedded with a
single search and rescue search and
rescue operation 24 miles off the coast
of Libya on day two and three of that
search and rescue operation we
encountered over 3,000 asylum seekers
floating and makeshift boats in the
middle of the ocean and with no other
rescue vessel in sight our rescue
operations mission and task was to try
to evacuate these thousands of human
beings from rafts and boats before they
sank or people died from exposure no
easy task on a 30 meter boat with 16
crew as people were pushed into the
water fell into the water sometimes
jumped into the water
we immediately faced the age-old dilemma
of the documentarian at what point if
any do you intervene and as people
floundered and often those without life
vests began to drown we pretty quickly
abandon any notions of pure observation
and simply put our cameras down and
helped pull people out of the sea and
into the zodiac before they could drown
and though the film that we made from
this experience may have been very
different if we'd made a different
choice and in fact the film we did make
may have suffered for it
our crew was ok with that in the end we
safely evacuated all but two people we
lost one woman to exposure and one man
who drowned in front of our zodiac
before we could reach him but over 3,200
human beings were pulled from the ocean
to continue their lives free from the
horrors of war and privation that they
were leaving behind the sequence you're
about to see is from the middle of the
film once first contact had been made
but before the search and rescue
operators were able to transport the
refugees and asylum-seekers to a safer
vessel
thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
nine reads about the political state of
the world or the environmental state of
the world and it's all going to hell in
the handcar
[Music]
so maybe the hope in the humans is some
totally mad irrational thing we've got
but we've got anyway
[Music]
you know rationality is worldly over
plate you know yeah the brain and the
mind yeah it's a useful tool that the
heart is where your real thinking comes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please welcome the nominee for a night
at the garden marshal Perry director
producer
[Applause]
you guys know Ryan Harrington he
constantly makes fun of my clothes and
he he told me at Sundance this year that
he thought I'd be more likely to win the
Oscar if I got rid of this string that I
wear around my glasses too so a night at
the garden I think we're gonna I think
we're gonna might be able to see the
whole thing in this were pretty close to
it I was told that it's the shortest the
shortest Doc nominated in 50 years I
don't know if that's something good or
bad I shouldn't maybe with that but I
first heard about this when I was at
dinner about a year and a half ago with
a friend of mine who's writing a
screenplay that takes place in New York
in 1939 and he'd been doing some
research and and he said did you know
that there was a rally in Madison Square
Garden were 20,000 Americans gathered to
celebrate the rise of Nazism and I
actually didn't believe him we argued
for a while and and I got home that
night and looked it up and sure enough
he was right and and there were some
historical documentaries that had little
5 or 10 second clips in them of that
rally and so I figured well if there's
10 seconds this thing there's got to be
more than that and so I called rich
Remsburg who's a archival researcher and
a friend and said hey could you look
around and see what you could find about
this thing and so he contacted the
National Archive and UCLA's archive and
Grinberg archive in a number of places
and discovered that they all had pieces
of this of this footage nobody had
really gathered it all together and and
like the National Archive had never had
filmed that they'd never scanned hi-def
before and and some places had audio
that video didn't match and video they
thought there was no audio but anyway
gathered it all together and and and I
remember just sort of starting to watch
it and was totally stunned I was stunned
that this is something that had happened
in my country in my
city where I live that I'd never heard
of and and I was stunned by how sort of
dark and surreal it seemed and I was
also stunned by how familiar it all
seemed you know you've got a you've got
a leader who attacks the press and
scapegoats minorities and cheers
violence against protesters and does all
that while wrapping it in the in the
symbols and icons of American patriotism
and so I first thought that maybe I
would make a more traditional
documentary where I would interview some
historians that would explain what this
was and one night sort of on a whim I
almost just just decided to see what it
would feel like if I edited it like a
Veritate documentary which is something
that I that I do sometimes I make
Faraday and other kinds of doctor
documentaries but and so you know what
would it feel like to just drop somebody
into this scene without any explanation
and and I found that I really liked that
it was disorienting and it was and and
it kind of sucked you in a little bit to
try to figure out what the hell was
going on like what what is this there
were there were a number of things that
I thought were particularly shocking
about it but the main thing that I
thought was talking about it was the
audience's reaction I feel like I've I
know that there are bad leaders in the
world but but when I saw the audience
the sort of lightness with which they
took this attack on people who would be
murdered by the millions in the next few
years in the years following us and and
these are these are people who would be
my neighbors in Brooklyn they've got you
know suits and ties and hats and dresses
and they've dropped off their kids that
afternoon with the babysitter on their
way to the rally and it was it was
just sort of a horrifying insight into
into humanity that that people who might
be my neighbors could be spun into it
could have a spell cast on them by by a
demagogue who was funny and charismatic
and mean and and anyway I thought that
this would be something that if we could
just release it to the world surely
people would would see it as a
cautionary tale and maybe become a
little more sensitized and vigilant when
they see demagogues today using similar
similar tactics so eighty the
anniversary of this rally is tomorrow
eighty years ago tomorrow is when this
rally took place and so last night the
team from field of vision Laura Poitras
and Charlotte cook and and and some
folks who work with me and some folks
who work at first look media got
together with a video artist and they
projected footage from our film on the
outside of Madison Square Garden and
it's beautiful and eerie and and
unsettling and there are some
photographs and some videos of it that
that that we're just finishing sorting
through and we're tossing out on social
media and stuff but it was so creepy
because it's a little bit translucent
the the projector was across the street
so it had to have a really strong throw
to get up onto the walls of Madison
Square Garden and and it's sort of as
you watch these people gathering and and
doing Nazi salutes and and and and
beating up protesters and it feels like
ghosts from 80 years ago coming back to
warn us about our current political
situation but anyway I know not to say
thanks but thanks to all of the rest of
the filmmakers and
and to the team that made this film
possible so here's some or maybe all of
the night at the garden
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
allegiance to the flag of the United
States of America and the Republic for
which it stands one nation indivisible
with liberty and justice
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
hello Megan American people
so I do not come before you tonight as a
complete station you all have heard of
me
though the choice for cold-pressed the
greenhorn I've flown him
and a long tail we with American ideals
the men that call Foreman shall be
returned to the American people
[Applause]
if you ask what we are deeply fighting
for our channel first our social just by
Gentile world United States second
I'll control Miller Union 3/4 choose
most out directed dominates
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please welcome the nominees for period
end of sentence
Rika's the top sheet director Melissa
Burton producer
[Applause]
[Laughter]
hi so I'm an English teacher in a high
school so you might rightly imagine that
my idea of excitement is a large pot of
tea and a well-placed comma and so I
think you will believe me when I say
that in 2013 when a group of students
approached me in my classroom and asked
me if I would be the faculty sponsor for
an organization called girls learn
international I embarked on what would
be the most profound journey of my life
and I know of many others as well girls
learn international is an organization
under the auspices of the feminist
majority foundation it seeks to give
high-school students a voice in the
global movement for equal access to
education for all genders
as part of that initiative they send
high-school students to the United
Nations at the age of 16 to be on the
floors of Equis Hawk in the United
Nations advocating for girls and women
and it was there that we learned about
this issue of girls their own age
missing school because of their period
because of the onset of menstruation and
we also learned at the same time about a
an inventor named Morgan Anthem who had
made a sanitary pad making machine that
would not only provide affordable pads
but would also provide a micro economy
for the women who ran the machine and so
maybe because we're from Los Angeles we
immediately thought we need to raise
awareness about this and we can only do
this through film we also need to get a
pad machine and get years worth of
supplies to the village in India we have
granita manga with us from India tonight
is our executive producer who just flew
in this morning I don't know how she's
awake but um but we were we were able to
do it and six years and many twists and
turns we we're here
I I'm right guy I'm the director of
period and a sentence and when I was
first brought on to direct this
documentary I remember walking into a
room it was at Oakwood school in Los
Angeles and it was Melissa's English
office and there were a group of like 15
or 16 year old young girls in front of
me and I learned that day that they
would ultimately be the executive
producers of this film so me fresh out
of USC film school literally a week out
of film school in 23 years old I'd never
made a documentary before and every
grain in my body was absolutely ecstatic
and so excited to to join this movement
when we arrived in India I think it was
transformative for me in so many ways
especially as a young woman seeing that
these women have gone their entire lives
never talking to another human being
about their periods about this natural
thing that we women experienced every
single month that they had gone their
entire lives thinking that they had some
something wrong with them there was
there was something inherently wrong
with them we learned there that this pad
machine would change these women's lives
and it would empower them and and it
would give them a voice a voice that
they felt they never had and I think
we've we've we've really seen how
powerful this movement can be and it's
been an incredible honor I get just
emotional thinking about it not because
I'm on my period or anything but it's
I've been waiting to use that line for a
while but it's it's it's been incredible
to see that this if a group of people
who have no experience in any of this
can really put their minds and their
hearts together and band together for
the greater good we really can change
the world and I think as a filmmaker
I've learned a lot of things in the past
couple of years especially how to do an
Oscars campaign but I think the most
important thing I've learned is that
documentary filmmaking is absolutely
essential for for our lives in fur
culture and and that we can actually
help to change the way a culture thinks
about menstruation through a documentary
film and that ultimately we've we've
been successful enough to start a global
movement and campaign to help women
worldwide own their bodies and own the
thing that that gives us strength so
thank you and this this clip that you're
about to see is actually the first three
minutes of the film and it will give you
a glimpse into their world thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh hey yes
Beethoven the photo Uganda coming look
there what about the hotel she said
what's the period of all you guys out
there cuz I'm asking to you why are you
not answering not American answers and I
said we Miriam how are you
[Music]
this is the girls problem and
Scott Pirie horn and automatic katana
Paris on Yeti America I'm the Peter
hotel mio-chan can import audited
catotti
tools on apartado which other Paris on
your TV : later would jaada jaada
Gillett ah easily Barbican la portada i
would Harbor on juniper Tejada cutter
p del r kv rattan ad me without their
dick take a couple of adult a challenge
court in case i'm natali battle patent
[Applause]
negamatter navi-x all talking about dr.
car which was in your path of damage a
dedicatory lucky psyllium Natalia please
welcome back Academy governor Rory
Kennedy thank you
let's just take a moment to really
applause these extraordinary shorts that
are so profound and relevant and
incredible filmmaking thank you again to
all of the short film makers and
congratulations to all of you it is now
my honor to introduce the five featured
documentaries that have been nominated
for an Academy Award as I mentioned
earlier it's been a particularly stellar
year for documentaries in regards to box
office this is the first year we've seen
for documentary films in the box office
make over ten million dollars and there
have been which is amazing and there
have been 15 documentaries that have
made over a million dollars and so
that's never happened before it's not
necessarily the most important metric
but I think it is relevant and something
to recognize I also appreciate that our
branch has given due consideration to
all the contenders even smaller films
without significant backup backing or
box office this year we had a hon
66 submissions in the feature
documentary category we reviewed every
single one of those films and so for the
nominees let's just take a moment to
again recognize how extraordinary it is
that your five films made it and have
been nominated for an Academy Award you
guys are the best of the best and we're
so appreciative and grateful for what
you have brought to the screen and
shared with us and a big congratulations
to all of you as a governor like Roger
working to broaden our membership I'm
also very happy to see that this year's
nominees reflect a diverse group of
filmmakers who took on diverse subject
matter we have an exploration of black
southern life a film about radical
Islamist family we bear witness to an
epic rock climb we are given a window
into the world of skateboard culture and
family violence and finally a biopic
celebrating a legendary Supreme Court
justice such different worlds all of
them and what it shows is how so many
subjects whether they are foreign to us
or familiar when approached by talented
filmmakers they can deepen our
understanding about the people around us
and the world in which we live it is my
honor now to introduce the feature
documentary section of our program I
hope you enjoy
please welcome the nominees for free
solo Elizabeth the Chive Vasarely
director producer Jimmy chin director
producer Evan Hayes producer Shannon
dill producing good evening I'm chai
this is Jimmy we are producing directing
partners and this is shannon and evan
who produced free solo with us I just
threw some water um you know just to
kind of pick up on what Rory was talking
about it like I think we all love stats
and one of my favorite stats in terms of
like measuring how moviegoers have been
supporting seeing and celebrating
nonfiction films this year is I think
that in 2018 nonfiction films made over
a hundred and thirteen million dollars
in the box office which is crazy like
you know it just doesn't happen um so
anyway it's been it's been a privilege
to be part of this community and to
quote our fellow nominee Bing Liu
hopefully it's the Iron Age and not the
Golden Age and this is just the
beginning
thing I borrowed that and I guess we
wanted to just talk like to introduce
the clip that we're showing tonight we
just kind of want to tell a story about
so for those of you who do not know I'm
free solo chronicles Alex Honnold dream
and attempt to free solo Yosemite is El
Capitan and a free solo means to climb
without ropes or any safety equipment so
literally climbing with your hands and
feet 3,200 square feet 3,200 feet in the
air um and you know this film yes and
Sue and him connect so this film like it
was kind of like a quagmire of ethical
questions as well as you know which led
to this idea of like why would we even
put ourselves in this situation because
it was so dangerous is so risky and it
had an existential ethical question that
Center being which is like a question
that applies to all nonfiction but it's
more extreme in this case which is that
in the act of filming are we likely to
cause him to fall is he more likely to
fall because we're there
and so we had to wrestle with this
pretty deeply and you know we kind of
came up with three we landed in three
places which was one do we believe in
what alex is doing and alex has thought
more deeply about his own mortality than
anyone else I know he has chosen to live
this life with great intention and we
were moved by that we were all so moved
by like he clearly does he alex is not a
maverick he's which sounds crazy but
when you see the movie like you
understand he's actually not a maverick
he very much wants to live he's just
incredibly precise and he's was a kid
who found it more scary to speak to
another person than to go out and climb
without a rope because without another
person there you have to climb without a
rope you know I'm a partner but he
always wanted to connect so he like he
saw other people eating vegetables
Soviet veggie he'd taught himself how to
eat vegetables
he was never hugged he taught himself
how to hug and that same kind of like
dedication to pursuing his dream doing
all the work and this idea that if you
work really really hard anything is
possible with something very moving to
us so we were gonna trip so what we
decided once we decided to embark on
this was that we were going to try our
best to mitigate our best you know to
mitigate the risks which was a
formidable task and like we're often
asked about our partnership so Jimmy and
I are married we're also directing and
producing partners and I come from the
nonfiction world like this is my sixth
film this is our second together and
Jimmy has had 20 years in the vertical
world as a professional climber and
National Geographic photographer so it
was but it was this kind of marriage of
skills and marriage of visions and this
idea that you know we could work
together and really get into the guts of
this film and wrestle with it and also
hope that it transcended the idea of
rock climbing like it was we were
inspired in a bigger way by Alex's story
and then I'm gonna turn into a love
story that became very complicated for
us to write I mean like it was we kind
of saw our relationship I'm like play
out with Alex and Sahni and that was a
lock word but also
interesting anyway so we're gonna tell
the story of the night before which is
the story we don't really talk about
very often the night before Alex's climb
so it was it also shows how much
preparation went into the into the
making of this film which is basically
our main rule was that the needs of the
film could never trump the needs of Alex
so for you know in a documentary that
actually translated like we could never
actually ask Alex if he was gonna climb
or when he's gonna climb so we just had
to be ready for two years or rather
Jimmy had to be ready for two years well
part of the filming process for us was
trying to figure out how to do the deal
with the logistics of filming behind
goal aspect of it and so we had built
this team of you know elite professional
climbers in order to film it and they
also had to be incredible filmmakers so
there wasn't a very big pool of people
but that to choose from but but part of
that idea of being a professional
climber was that everybody on the team
had been had worked on both sides of the
lens and we were very sensitive to what
it feels like to be filmed and when you
introduce a camera to a situation and
that was the kind of sensitivity that we
really needed to bring to this film
because we wanted to insulate Alex from
the pressures of production and so the
night before we went so like we weren't
allowed to ask Alex when he was gonna
free solo but I did have two
conversations with him which was one I'm
pregnant with James our second child you
were not allowed to free solo in these
two months two years later I was like oh
it's our elder daughters like last day
of nursery school oh yeah so she was at
graduation at nursery school in New York
and I was in the room hanging out with
Alex with my DP and he was kind of
stretching and we were all kind of knew
that he was getting close to this moment
where he was maybe gonna free solo I'll
cap it of course we couldn't ask him and
it takes days to rig this thing so we're
kind of on pins and needles but it's 5
o'clock at night and we
figure it well there's no way he's gonna
go tomorrow so my DP and I start talking
about well maybe we should go climbing
tomorrow and Alex looks over and he says
what if I decided to go scrambling
tomorrow he won't say free soloing he
said scrambling and and we were like oh
really and he's like yeah I'm thinking
about scrambling tomorrow and we were
like okay well we were hoping to go
climbing and he's like no I'm serious
I'm gonna go scrambling tomorrow and I
was like okay and then he said do you
think you guys are gonna be ready if I
go scrambling tomorrow and I was like
yeah that's fine no problem takes three
days to rig this stuff you know totally
casual and he's like okay well I'm going
scrambling tomorrow so I was like okay
so I'm sitting there and we're trying to
play it cool so I hang out for another
45 minutes just playing it cool like
we're not in a big rush and he said
don't you guys have to go get ready and
we're like yeah it's fine the Sun is
still on the approach I don't want to
climb up there when it's hot you know
and then of course we ran out after 45
minutes I made the call to the team
everybody deployed but I think it's
indicative of kind of a lot of the
issues that we were kind of dealing with
like never making him feel like there
was a pressure for him to do this and
trying to be sensitive and insulating
him from all of the the kind of ethical
questions that we were dealing with and
being planned for the day in every
single way like we were editing at the
same time as we're shooting for two
years and as Alex rehearsed the climb
like our high angle crew and Jimmy
rehearsed the shots so as we were
editing we were able to refine you know
the three money shots we absolutely had
to get for the story and it allowed us
to be ready on the big day but he did
wait till after marina graduated from
nursery school and I did arrive just in
time but anyways this clip is yeah this
clip gets to their relationship and also
kind of the ethical questions we were
here we were negotiating yes yeah
did you take ibuprofen this morning
mm-hmm I'm going to right now I'll go
for your ankle mm-hmm I'm not like super
stoked when he goes soloing because he's
already a big part of my life I Telex I
love him all the time and he shows me
that he loves me all the time
but I also tell him that I also need
words of affection we work on
in terms of learning how to communicate
emotion alex has a long way to go I said
sometimes I'm gonna tell you how I feel
and I just need you to say it totally
makes sense that you feel that way he
was like yeah I can understand why you
feel that way it's like I don't really
think that you do but I'm glad that
you're trying
outs we have excellent team skills I
think we're not quite killing it but
we're doing great I'm very happy for
Alex and Sonya that it works so well and
I'm I think I'm just impressed by their
relationship but to free solo at that
level you really have to have the mental
Airmen having that romantic relationship
around is detrimental to that armor you
have to focus and inherently a close
romantic relationship removes that armor
and you kind of can't have both at the
same time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's always something that has to
give you the confidence to go out and
and three solo a route so sometimes that
confidence just comes from feeling super
super fit
sometimes that confidence comes through
preparation and rehearsal but I mean
there's always something that makes you
feel ready
[Music]
there's something to be said for like
sewing a bunch of [ __ ] till I get
into that right space
[Music]
real and as much as I trust Alex and I
know that he's really methodical if
you're pushing the edge eventually you
find the edge but there's some things
that you're like well you just have to
push that bark if they're just they're
just that gold you know God is that cool
[Music]
there's incremental advances that happen
in all kinds of things but every once in
a while there's just this iconic leap
soloing all cap if he pulls this off is
this quantum leap it is hard to imagine
somebody up there by themselves without
a rope where's pretty much all the other
big cliffs around here I can kind of get
it how many times have you sold both a
three-star well asked man three or four
times but the rostrum I mean literally
like 50 60 wait you've sold the rostrum
50 or 60 times it was like part of the
circuit and I would go there and I've do
it at least twice like I was just glom
on huh not like out of fear but just
kind of like it sounds so tight yeah I
love that about sewing my footwork gets
really good yeah really yeah totally but
it's not for anybody else
this is just because you have to rest
man even like we want to fill me up fill
you up there and I'm like not interested
not even slightly for me it was so
incredibly important to be doing it for
the right reasons I mean I I think I'm
still doing everything for the right
reasons that I'm still totally stoked
but I feel like from the outside
observer you know they'd be like oh he's
got a movie crew like clearly that's the
wrong reasons you know the worst thing
about having a film crew is if it
changes your mindset
please welcome the nominees for Hale
County this morning this evening rahmel
ross director producer jocelyn barnes
producer sue Kim producer we thought
there's gonna be way less people here
and so we're not underprepared we're
just gonna do something we didn't expect
so just to respond to Chai's everyone
likes stats I personally dislike stats
but that's but that's strictly because
of the way in which you know
statistically black folks are kind of
represented and just the general
relationship between poverty and you
know access to resources and stuff and
so I will start with this what if and
I've said this before but I think it's
worth saying now what if what if every
single image of an American was made by
the British what if every single for the
history actually not every let's say
like 95.9 like how would us Americans
feel what we feel represented will be
felt like people understand us that's
kind of what has been the case for black
culture it's just just haven't had the
opportunity to make or image ourselves
which means I would argue that no one
here including myself has has never seen
a black person before who actually you
might not even know what that looks like
and so my entrance into making the film
with Jocelyn Barnes and Sue and many
many many others really close team my
currency and robb maus was to
photography and sort of talking about
the problem of the image and the problem
of cinema as much as its power and as
much as it's you know versatility and
it's visceral Ness and so what should I
say now oh yeah so oh no this was
important too right so Golden Age of
cinema
I don't know Golden Age of documentary I
don't know I would like to to hope I
mean to me Golden Age speaks to money
and it speaks to
industry speaks to consumption a speaks
to reduction it speaks to like this sort
of offering of easy narratives and so
I'm kind of I would love for it to be
talked about like enlightenment in the
documentary genre or like this new age
of Revelation
more so than we're making a lot of money
which i think is wonderful because it
gives more people access it means that
there's more platforms but I also think
that it's more complicated than that I
think that the problem with diversity is
that you know if it's not diversity of
perspective then the diversity means
nothing if it's not you know talking
about the form of the way in which the
stories are being offered then it
doesn't mean much because they're still
peddling in the same logic that gives us
easy connection to ideas that are
extremely complex and the reason why
we're in this age of despair and and
issues but he'll County is a film that
is extremely interested in shooting from
the interior de tee of the sort of black
experience as vast as that is from Hell
County sort of you know we had 1300
hours of footage and that's because the
idea was to let meaning come not to seek
it out
so what happens when you go into
someone's life and you're like I'm gonna
do this you end up like fulfilling your
own understanding of what that issue is
you look for markers with meaning that
you're familiar with occasionally you're
surprised what happens if you you sit
there past that moment and past the next
moment you realize that there's you know
um there's myriad ways that a person can
be represented a place can be
represented that perhaps your experience
of being there it's a true form of
knowledge at that community and of the
issue at hand and so how do you then
offer that to an audience and how do you
then use all of the tools of cinema to
you know provide something that is
irreducible something that is yeah
complex and vast and can be constantly
you know engaged with something that I
think which I'm interested specifically
in this term is like how do you renew
the encounter how do you renew the
encounter of blackness how do you renew
the encounter of marginalized
communities how do we like get past the
way in which we think we know or we
under
and places that we've never lived nor
situations we've never actually been so
our clip is a our clip is is like not so
long but um and it's also it's I think
it's important to say that it's really
difficult as all films are to show clips
that are small but specifically I think
for this film but I think even
specifically for this clip because it
comes after a moment in which Bert
Williams appears who is this really
famous blackface actor who was talented
but also I'm sort of tragically forced
to sort of pedal in the stereotype of
what mainstream society thought he was
and so he sort of in the film he's
liberated in some sense we sort of come
in and we burned down the antebellum
home he comes out of the shadows quite
literally and so this sort of montage is
almost when you're you're allowed to
sort of understand or in engage with the
black banal in a way that you know
conceptually and theoretically would be
like sort of post post race not possible
but you know oh yeah and Bert Williams
is a man of blackness
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he'll be a good moving your nothing and
cow the world without good
[Music]
don't be like a fighter boo to your PO
leave right he's prone II know when you
got no guns in the world
[Music]
[Music]
who's gonna meet me halfway
I'm gonna get away you don't you back
[Music]
got my body going that got my body go
got my bodyguard for you if you were not
your way
[Music]
a table please welcome the nominees for
minding the gap Bing Liu
director-producer dian kuang producer I
first saw a very rough cut of mine the
gap three years ago and what I saw broke
my heart and gave me hope I got to know
Bing and the more I got to know him it
also broke my heart that gave me so much
hope I he was a one-man band at that
time directing editing shooting and I
have to say I'm so grateful that he let
me join him on his journey
thanks to him I remember the first time
we met we met at a coffee shop and you
didn't finish your coffee so I finished
it for you I would do it alone for a
while but I feel like you know with the
help of car temp Quinn but I feel like
it's when I started working with people
that's when I really started having a
lot of great memories and that was one
of them
I think another memories when I start
working my Carter Josh and and then
eventually staying over at his house and
his guest bedroom for like a month and a
half I remember when
Josh called me one night when we had we
were editing our Airbnb in Venice with
Josh lives and we were trying to find an
ending to the film and how to you know
like just take care of all these
multiple endings and he's he called me
he was like hey man I just smoked some
weed and I was I just watched an episode
of bloodline and it did this awesome
montage we should try that and so I
tried it that night and then we watched
you in the morning and then we went
surfing came back and talked about it
and I mean those it's I'm just so happy
for all the people I met in this journey
and all the people in many of you are
who are in this gym I also didn't know
that there wasn't gonna be a panel in
town hour ago which is probably my
thought I didn't read my emails like but
the clip you're gonna see is is it I
should probably say my film has you know
it's set in the world of skateboarding
and it's so that the what you're about
to see is me going back into my story a
little bit and then it's sort of the
ball up in the air about why some of the
characters love skateboarding how they
use in their lives
this the board you buy here ah think you
did a while ago I remember we had this
board in the shop I don't buy how much
anymore does that I'll skate that much
anymore dude tell me about it skate
really enough I don't really remember
when I first met you I I just you were
just like kid that was always there you
know like you'd come into the skate shop
I don't know we talked about random
stuff and then that happened with a lot
of kids and they could come in and be
like yeah dude my parents soccer this is
going on and they've come in and unload
you know but you were introverted and I
didn't know and I remember distinctly
asked you if you were gay you remember
that at all no like I asked you like
dude are you gay like what's what do you
you know like I knew I knew you had some
huge weight on you and you were like nah
you know but I can't remember when you
opened up to me about your mom itself
but I did oh yeah you never really told
me about anything about what was going
on with you and I guess in retrospect
now when I look at it I'm like I should
have hired that out like I could tell
from with you from the very beginning
like skateboarding meant more to you
than just being cool and having friends
like it was your thing to like
get away it was kind of a life-or-death
thing
[Music]
to other people it's funny haha you know
these guys are crazy but in reality I
think it's a control thing you [ __ ]
have to control the most of my new small
details to make you feel normal in a
world that's not normal it would kind of
be like a drug anyway like I could
seriously be on the verge of having a
[ __ ] mental breakdown but as long as
I'm able to go skate and I'm completely
fine
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
as soon as it affected the drug wears
off it just comes back to you please
welcome the nominees for uh fathers and
sons Tom aldair key director and cigar
free Rick producer if a came up pretty
sir Tobias and zebra producer not only
us get tired so my team just arrived
from Berlin the jet lag so it's six
o'clock in the morning for us thank you
so much
I mean I tried to catch the light I
couldn't recognize I get confused all
the time looking left and dressed to
know the times and - so fathers and sons
since the long journey through radical
the radicalism radical family and the
moment we start doing this film I mean
always when I'm asked somebody asking
about motivation I start to talk and
till he's taught me because it's
complicated me as a as a Syrian like and
what happened to my country and how its
end like it's above everything it's
under the nightmare still happening and
how we can describe this how we can tell
this to the people without with the less
violence because people I believe in
documentary get tired and not in
documentary from news actually always
get tired from seeing Syrian blood on
the ground and sinker catastrophe sink
just dead people every day and every day
so they there's still something missing
the image so we tried to go more deeply
into the what what house what's
happening how it's happening why there
is a violence in our world why people
become more radicalism why start for a
good purpose and end as a nightmare
so why nobody does anything and
then all these think uestions everything
go come to my mind
why did my main character and my
previous film become radicalism and more
religion instead of after all the sacred
vows be like it's difficult
all those thousand question like lead us
to go and make a story about the
childhood about the shared code of sama
thirteen years old his father named him
sama because he's in love with Osama bin
Laden and and so about people who don't
have a choice in their lives in the
moment they're born maybe we are all
don't have choice maybe we are lucky to
end up here to be what we want to be as
a filmmaker maybe we all love films and
we do this when and we live from this
film so so it's a it's a story of it's
an arc real-time shooting about a child
innocent end up as a jihadist and he
still like inside him he still have his
childhood is it a possibility to change
this I believe it's a possibility after
this experience to an heart filled in
this family so observing him and being
close to him and thinking about him
thinking about my son because we all
children's we all sounds we all fathers
we all appreciate family which we we
don't know sometimes we give wrong
things we do think that from love to our
kids but in the what we we do the worse
to them with without understanding that
we do that the father and the film love
his kids and you see the savvycard on
him but he he sacrifice with him for a
duel Yugi
so the uprise I believe the operas of
radicalism is very strong and there is
big way of still happening not only a
religion also nationals and every people
become really radical they don't want to
listen they just build walls and walls
and walls between their neighbors I mean
we selectively we select one scene it's
like the first scene
the first morning for us in this family
in this society
it's a morning we wake up and the kid
bring a bird and he tried to imitate his
father you understand from this thing
the legacy of violence what how the
meaning of growing up in radical with
the radical father so it's exactly as
it's editing the film and here we are
and we appreciate to be here I'm so
happy to be with the team there and here
everywhere thank you
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please welcome the nominees for our BG
Betsy West director producer and Julie
Cohen director producer hi everybody
Wow I agree with Talal I mean we feel
extraordinarily lucky to be here with
this amazing group of films it was four
years ago that Julie and I were talking
about Ruth Bader Ginsburg and how she
had just kind of blown up on the
Internet as the notorious RBG it was in
the wake of several stinging descents
that she had written on the Supreme
Court as it was moving to the right
people were responding to her words and
there were tote bags and there were mugs
and t-shirts and even tattoos extolling
RBG and you know Julie and I had both
worked on a project about the modern
women's movement and we knew that there
was a whole other part of her story how
as a young lawyer she really became the
legal architect of the women's movement
you know arguing and winning equality
for women under the US Constitution so
you know we're talking about doing this
project and thinking that it's going to
take you know to do a film about as a
sitting Supreme Court justice it's going
to take some time and at one point I
remember we were saying gee I wonder if
people will be interested in this when
we get done I mean has RBG peaked
literally yeah so I guess we'll cut to
today with the news I imagine that
you've heard that
after her surgery in December Justice
Ginsburg was back on the court for all
our oral arguments back on the bench for
the first time today and you know it's
just sort of reflecting the the process
you know everything through that four
years I mean not that the level of
interest seemed so high and yet through
the whole process of making the film and
then from the time of the release of the
film a year ago things seemed to happen
by the Year by the month by the week by
the day that made RBG's story feel ever
more relevant and ever ever more a focus
but for the film we really were trying
to balance and weave telling the current
day story and some elements of Verret a
documentary with a lot of history and we
decided pretty early on that we weren't
afraid of history we weren't afraid of
things that were audio tape only we
weren't afraid of getting into our Kivus
stuff we wanted to see RBG as she is now
an amazing 85 year old woman as well as
her whole life so the clip that you're
gonna see really is in the history mode
of our of our film and here it is
it was an afternoon argument so I was
first up in the afternoon and I didn't
dare have lunch that day she seemed
nervous her eyes were wide with sort of
anticipation
it's very intense and austere and
important and very male and it's the
whole thing feels like I was I was
really kind of scared we sat down at the
counsel table and I had all these huge
case books for me to help her with
sights and the court began with the IAEA
and here here we are having business
before the Supreme Court of the United
States are admonished to draw near and
give their attention for the court is
now sitting this is Jen's Berger I was
terribly terribly nervous but then I
looked up and the justices and I thought
I have a captive audience I knew that I
was speaking to men who didn't think
there wasn't any such thing as
gender-based discrimination and my job
was to tell them it really exists
mr. Chief Justice and may it please the
court
women today face discrimination in
employment as pervasive and more subtle
than discrimination encountered by
minority groups sex classifications
imply a judgment of inferiority the sex
criterion stigmatizes when it is used to
protect women from competing for higher
paying jobs promotions it assumes that
all women are preoccupied with home and
children these distinctions have a
common effect they help keep woman in
her place a place inferior to that
occupied by men in our society it was
not a single question I just went on
speaking and I at the time wondered are
they just indulging me and not listening
or am i telling them something they
haven't heard before and are they paying
attention
the justices were just glued to her I
don't think they were expecting to have
to deal with something as powerful as a
shear force of her argument that was
just all-encompassing and they were
there to talk about a little statute in
the in the government code I mean it was
it was just we we seize the moment to
change American society and asking the
court to declare sex a suspect right
Tyrion we earned a position forcibly
stated in 1837 by Sarah Grimke noted
abolitionist an advocate of equal rights
for men and women she said I asked no
favor for my sex brethren is that they
take their feet off our necks
well so this is my favorite night of
Oscar week because when you see all
these films together when you see all 10
of them together
there's no denying the transformative
power of documentary film you know for
us document making a documentary it's
painful we struggle we are sometimes we
think we have nothing we these
filmmakers have spent years toiling away
not because they thought they were gonna
rub shoulders with Lady Gaga or Melrose
or or even for the red carpet because I
don't think any of these filmmakers
thought they would be here today they
would be walking the red carpet in
Hollywood so this what they've done and
the work they've done they're here
because it touched our hearts and it
touched our soul and in each of these
films as a potential to change our lives
so thank you and a round of applause for
these amazing filmmakers
and thank you guys for coming tonight
that concludes our show and see you at
the Oscars
you